Olá pessoal tudo bem Aqui o Dr Alan
Machado Dutra médico há mais de 25 anos
e hoje eu quero explicar para vocês como
preparar o chá verde conhecido como chá
da
longevidade e você precisa aprender de
forma adequada para não perder as suas
propriedades incríveis pra saúde porque
muita gente prepara o chá verde e toma
diariamente achando que está conseguindo
os melhores benefícios mas na verdade
está tomando o chá de forma errada e até
prejudicando a saúde e até mesmo o
consumo excessivo ou horário que você
toma faz diferença esse chá pode trazer
problemas sérios Então vamos lá para
vocês entenderem como o chá verde que é
extraído da planta chamada Camélia
censes pode ser muito benéfico pra sua
saúde quando tomado da maneira correta
uma simples xícara de chá verde contém
uma grande quantidade de antioxidantes
bem potentes Olha que interessante um
estudo mostrou que tomar apenas uma
xícara de chá verde tem o mesmo
potencial antioxidante que comer 1 kg de
frutas frescas isso porque o chá verde é
repleto de polifenóis especialmente as
catequinas que são compostos fantásticos
paraa nossa saúde uma das principais
catequinas famosas pelos efeitos
benéficos do chá verde é a famosa
epigalocatequina
galato conhecida pela sigla
egcg para vocês terem uma ideia ela
oferece de 25 a 100 vezes mais atividade
antioxidante do que a própria vitamina C
ou vitamina e mas vamos falar rapidinho
dos inúmeros benefícios do chá verde o
que vou comentar aqui é baseado em
diversos estudos cujos links eu vou
deixar na descrição para quem quiser se
aprofundar mais como eu já mencionei o
chá verde possui uma atividade
antioxidante muito potente e essa
atividade pode ajudar a melhorar a
função cerebral prevenir distúrbios
cognitivos Isso significa que o chá
verde pode ser usado na prevenção de
doenças como Alzheimer E parson ajudando
na melhora da cognição da memória do
raciocínio Além disso o chá verde pode
ser interessante para quem tem
osteoporose pois as suas propriedades
podem fortalecer os ossos há também
evidências de que o chá verde pode
prevenir e combater as cares dentárias
mas o fator mais interessante aqui é que
as catequinas presentes no chá verde são
potentes agentes
antiinflamatórios Portanto o chá verde
tem a capacidade de combater a
inflamação no nosso corpo ajudando em
doenças inflamatórias desde doenças
inflamatórias do intestino até mesmo
doenças como artrite e artrose Outro
ponto interessante e importante é que o
chá verde tem um foco significativo na
prevenção e no combate ao câncer ele é
muito estudado para essa finalidade e
tem vários estudos mostrando que os
polifenóis do chá verde possuem
propriedades que combatem vários tipos
de câncer é o caso de pele bexiga ou
ovário mama colo retal que é intestino
grosso pâncreas pulmão e próstata tem
estudos também que mostram que pessoas
que consomem chá verde diariamente
possuem níveis mais baixos de danos
causados por inflamação crônica e também
tem menos danos ao DNA Além disso há
evidências de que o consumo de chá verde
pode retardar a degradação e a perda da
nossa cartilagem corporal Então quem tem
problemas nas cartilagens pode se
beneficiar do consumo dessa bebida e
esse chá também pode ajudar a regular os
níveis de açúcar no sangue promovendo
uma digestão saudável auxiliando na
perda de peso pois ajuda a melhorar o
metabolismo Além disso o chá verde pode
ajudar a prevenir doenças cardíacas pois
Combate A inflamação crônica e ajuda a
equilibrar o colesterol no sangue outro
benefício do chá verde é sua capacidade
de proporcionar Uma Mente mais afiada
porém mais
relaxada melhorando a tensão no dia a
dia isso torna a opção ótima para
pessoas que se sentem nervosas ou
ansiosas o chá verde contém um composto
chamado LT anina um aminoácido que tem
um efeito antistress um efeito calmante
só que é uma calma focada ajuda a
melhorar o humor a controlar a ansiedade
para vocês terem uma ideia mais de 50%
dos aminoácidos livres na folha do chá
verde são desse aminoácido lanina ele é
muito top portanto incorporar o chá
verde no seu dia a dia de forma adequada
vai trazer muito esse benefício calmante
mas há dois problemas que eu acho muito
importante alertar vocês o chá verde
Pode ser sim
tóxico especialmente ao seu fígado e
levar Inclusive a hepatite aguda o
problema está no excesso muitas pessoas
consomem o chá verde diversas formas
tomam o chá várias vezes ao dia colocam
o chá verde no suco consomem bebidas
prontas na base de chá verde e até tomam
cápsulas de chá verde esse consumo
exagerado pode levar à toxicidade do
fígado
hepatotoxicidade resultando Como Eu
mencionei numa hepatite aguda isso já
foi rel atado na medicina e não se sabe
ao certo mas provavelmente pessoas que
já estão com fígado sobrecarregado com
toxinas ou com alguma doença hepática
pregressa são as mais afetadas por essas
consequências isso porque o seu fígado
não vai suportar uma carga excessiva de
chá verde o segundo problema é que o chá
verde é rico em taninos que podem inibir
absorção de ferro após uma refeição rica
em ferro de fonte vegetal não M então se
você sofre de anemia ou está com a
ferritina baixa no sangue recomendo
evitar beber chá verde próximo das
refeições a diferença entre o remédio e
veneno como diria Hipócrates é a dose
portanto é essencial que você consuma o
chá verde com moderação duas xícaras por
dia são suficientes para aproveitar os
benefícios sem correr risco
desnecessário o chá verde tem muitos
benefícios incríveis mas é importante
respeitar as doses recomendadas para
garantir que eles sejam aliado e não um
vilão para sua
saúde para vocês terem uma ideia tem
estudos que compararam quanto uma xícara
de chá verde tem de antioxidantes e um
chá verde de boa qualidade feito com
folhas ou na forma do conhecido matcha
pode fornecer até 180 MG do egcg o igalo
catechin galato isso por xícara então se
você tomar uma ou duas xícaras vai ter
bastante benefício muitas pessoas tomam
várias xícaras ao dia fazem um ou 2 l de
chá verde vão bebendo ao longo do dia
mas é melhor você não se arriscar como
eu já expliquei numa xícara você já tem
cerca de 180 MG de antioxidantes se
estiver tomando um chá verde de boa
qualidade Se você usar uma versão
descafeinada essa concentração vai ser
menor aproximadamente 60 MG por
xícara e se você consumir chá verde de
má qualidade ou desses prontos
engarrafados benefício será mínimo menos
de 10 mg por xícara eu não sou a favor
do uso de cápsulas de chá verde sem
Orientação médica se seu médico
prescrever ou está te acompanhando
joinha mas fazer isso por conta própria
sem uma avaliação sem acompanhamento
dessas cápsulas pode ser perigoso e como
preparar o chá verde para ter os
melhores benefícios Então já falamos que
o excesso Deve ser evitado porque
algumas pessoas vão ter problemas então
Vamos considerar que você pode tomar até
três xícaras de chá verde por dia o que
está de bom tamanho ok muito bom tamanho
e como preparar vamos lá primeiro busque
um chá verde de qualidade pois esse de
saquinho vendido nos supermercados Ou
aquele eles vendidos soltos sem
conhecimento de marca ou de origem devem
ser evitados então para cada xícara
aproximadamente 200 ml de água você vai
ferver essa
água a temperatura é crucial pra
preparação do chá verde a água deve
estar por volta de 80º C para garantir a
extração dos antioxidantes se a
temperatura estiver muito baixa você não
vai conseguir fazer a extração adequada
desses antioxidantes obtendo menos de
50% deles e se a água tiver quente
demais acima de 120 150º também não
obterá os benefícios então a temperatura
ideal é por volta de 80º C depois de
aquecer a água você vai colocar uma
colher de chá das folhas de chá verde na
xícara e despejar a água então para uma
xícara de água uma colher de chá das
folhas é o suficiente você pode abafar a
xícara colocando algo por cima e deixar
em infusão por um tempo entre 2 a 5
minutos é importante beber o chá logo
depois de preparado enquanto está morno
o chá que você acabou de fazer é
superior ao chá que ficou parado por
várias
horas evite adicionar Leite ao seu chá
verde já que isso pode diminuir o
potencial de alguns
antioxidantes por outro lado adicionar
um pouco de limão pode de aumentar os
benefícios dessa excelente bebida
melhorando a absorção das catequinas em
até cinco vezes então chá verde com
limão é top é uma ótima combinação o
mata que é o chá verde em pó feito de
folhas moídas Ultra finas também pode
ser utilizado ele possui uma quantidade
um pouco maior de antioxidantes em
relação as folhas tradicionais o preparo
do matcha é um pouco diferente e pode
variar conforme o tipo e o fabricante eu
vou deixar o link na descrição para quem
quiser saber como preparar o mata de
forma correta cada tipo de Mata pode ter
suas peculiaridades então é importante
seguir as instruções do
fabricante compartil os vídeos bem a de
alguém pode mudar também no
[Música]
canal Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração e
você é o quê você é fera